foreign
we've been seeing a lot of fentanyl
pills a lot of methamphetamines also
every once in a while we do get heroin
and cocaine but right now the way that
these packages are wrapped it looks like
possible meth
okay so now we're just gonna open one of
the first packages
um depending what we see determines the
test we're going to be using
it
and then from the initial it looks like
they're blue pills
so these are uh possibly fentanyl pills
this is our rapid response test for
Fentanyl
I'm going to extract the pill from the
package
I'm going to swap it with the solution
and then using a test strip it's going
to determine whether it is fentanyl it's
positive or fentanyl or not
it'll give you one line if it's positive
it'll give you two lines if it's
negative
it's a red line that's going to come out
[Music]
so that red line right there
the first package we just popped open
right now is positive for fennel so the
nest snacks right now will open some
packages make sure that they're the same
contents are different if it's different
we'll test it with a different type of
tests
so right now in the opening we just see
that it looks exactly the same the first
package so we can assume that it's the
same kind of narcotic
foreign
[Music]
they are all small pills even in the
packages look different they have the
same uh narcotic inside conceal inside
now we need to weigh them to see how
much narcotics we have
1.86 kilograms
it was a good day whenever you get able
to seize any type of narcotic the
further it leaves Nogales the more
pricier it gets so it's always a good
day when we take these narcotics out of
the streets
here in CVP it's a team effort we used a
lot of different tools today we had our
primary officers we had our canines we
also had different other methods to
search and with the use of all that
we're able to secure some narcotics
today
[Music]